done for you because that's not the main point of this exercise but bear in mind that it is something that we will
require practicing and running a large scale job isn't always the straightforward we will delve into this
further in episode 4 your final circuit is going to obviously look a lot messier than the circuit that ran on 5 cubits
but on the other hand I feel like looking at this circuit and seeing how many gates it has and knowing that you
have the capability to actually run this on real Quantum processors is pretty
impressive and this was my final solution you can see that the algorithm is certainly capable of grouping these
nodes into two groups allegedly identifying the best Max cut that divides them as going from the two sets
to the max cut line itself is Trivial anywhere the color changes along the lines that connect the nodes designates
where the max cut line should be drawn when I ran it the max cut value I was able to achieve is
84 so try it for yourself and let me know if you get something similar in the comments try three layers maybe four try
changing the weights between the nodes and see how that changes the outcome there's a lot of interesting experiments
that we can run with qaa now remember it is not guaranteed that I just found the best possible
solution we know it's a good solution but for fun I challenge you to try to beat me see if you can get something
that's better than 84 in conclusion qaoa is a very Dynamic
algorithm and there are a lot of heuristics and much to still be explored it gives a lot of room for learning new
things about the field of optimization in general there has been a lot of work recently in the optimization space as
evidenced by all of the archive papers that have recently been published online on qaoa or optimization and what is
really cool is that finally not all of the these papers are Theory papers theorists have been working in studying
qaoa for years but now the experimentalists are getting involved because we finally have the hardware
like IBM's processors that are capable of running many of these experiments we're moving from the imaginative space
to the real world and that's very exciting yes there is still a lot of work to be done and there are still
plenty of errors that we need to figure out how to deal with but we're making quick progress and you watching this
video if you've made it this far are capable of running these experiments yourself please go try running your own
100 Cubit experiment and let us know how it went follow along with the tutorial and you'll be in good hands and if you
have any questions or get stuck don't worry we all felt that way or had those same questions when we first started
learning this do your best let us know what questions you come across and we'll see you next time
[Music]